Oh what is going on YouTube not seen
some [ __ ] and we've seen a lot of these
videos but people get smacked up but God
for those of you up there who have not
seen this video this video made my toes
curl
now when the video starts we don't
really know what happened before the
conversation but it starts off with this
girl talking a lot of [ __ ] you gotta
come at a boy Jackie that came out in
1990 bro now if you don't know you could
always tell somebody's level of
wretchedness
by the hand movements cuz I understand
when a ghetto [ __ ] get mad it's just as
less you do it in bondage for deaf
people is [ __ ] never seen that [ __ ] they
don't know what to do with the hands it
ends up at the back of the head but how
will [ __ ] your ass up but you won't talk
you gonna talk to me if you want when
ghetto people get mad they look like
they painting with an invisible
paintbrush you shouldn't cry me
[ __ ] try me and of course after
a few minutes of getting more rain and
get a smack upside his head with a
stiletto
this [ __ ] dead ahh now on a
real [ __ ] let's get into this now you
know me I generally do not condone
physical violence I know you think I'm a
hypocrite but if you had a [ __ ] brain
I joke about that [ __ ] and the most
ridiculous type of way oh [ __ ] you in
the cactus I will superglue my dick to a
night like any of that [ __ ] is real I'm
gonna attach a grenade to your butthole
and the reason why a majority of the
time I don't really condone violence
because as I got older I got a lot
smarter I realized that when I tend to
solve my issues with violence and show
that that person has a lot of control
over my emotions and Plus like I said
I'm older now so you know I'm with white
people on this one when [ __ ] goes down
IV the cops cops must we break lag of
that are you trying to get [ __ ] up I'm
calling the cops my button watered it
but now that I've said my piece and I
put that out there can we have a moment
of realness for a second y'all got to
admit this [ __ ] had it coming
oh my god now growing up we have been
taught this universal rule and it has
been ingrained in every fiber of my
moral being
you never
your hands on a woman but let's say you
can't sing this is your wedding coming
come on listen if it wasn't this
eight-foot Sasquatch with that mouth of
yours you want to got clocked eventually
now I'll put this out there and I know
it may not be a popular idea but [ __ ] it
if you have the ball sack or vaginal
canal to put your hands on a man or
woman be willing to face the
consequences now once again nobody has
the right to put their hands on another
person but [ __ ] that applies to YouTube
cuz can we also agree on one more thing
this girl was ghetto as [ __ ] you know
how we know you get out is because every
time you do some [ __ ] you gotta cause a
[ __ ] scene thug aleena you gotta make
an announcement it's not grabbing
everybody's attention and [ __ ] like you
read the Ten Commandments picturing
Moses so let me be real once again there
aren't a certain small cluster of women
out there that believe they can strike
hit curse whatever berate the men as
much as they want because they will
never ever have any consequences to deal
with brother you do not have to go that
route and slap the Postel out of her
head ah once again can we agree on this
I can see why you did it now for those
of you who don't know there was actually
a follow-up interview to see how her
condition was after that slap and
apparently her hairline now starts at
the back of a neck man or woman it does
not matter violence is violent so please
be sensible before you decide to put
your hands or even berate somebody on
the public this is not a gender issue
this is a respect issue she chose the
rough to put her hands on somebody
thus she had to face the consequences
now I'm not saying that I condone the
violence once again but we could see why
it happened I don't even understand why
the [ __ ] you would attack somebody who
is eight feet tall Abdulla lucky babies
for breakfast at a certain point when
you got speck I literally thought I saw
your spirit leading body and say [ __ ]
how what is going on YouTube yes yes yes
now if you notice I made uploading a
little bit more blog so now yes I will
have the regular Sunday uploads but I
keep on telling you there's a certain
date when I put up these other ones I
don't know I'm just gonna put it out
throughout the week so please follow me
out on Twitter Facebook Instagram
whatever and you will find out when I'm
gonna release these extra videos but
Sunday there will always be a video only
its order this utterly funny bad fit
once again has not stopped but I worked
on this project with
latias this week so we'll be coming out
with a sketch on December 1st December
so stay tuned for that and remember I
will see you guys this Sunday maybe
Friday and Wednesday who knows who knows
who knows god damn it why the [ __ ] is
everybody texting me right now nobody
texts me for days and suddenly y'all
miss me [ __ ] whatever dude and
let's be real once again there's a what
the [ __ ] [ __ ]